chad is on the line and Dayton Ohio hey
Chad how are you pretty good
better than I deserve how can I help
after 13 years old we're getting on the
same finances having trouble hearing you
can you make sure you're talking
directly into your phone please yeah
much better thank you okay sorry about
that unfortunately because of stupidity
in my three hundred thousand dollars in
student loan debt and so we just got
done with the retirement and college
planning class and in some success to
get to a point where you are free other
than your home before you start doing
that so we have three hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars in debt from
college are you a doctor or a lawyer I
was a stupid youth who took out student
stuff I didn't need to and what is your
degree in operations research operations
research and what does that mean you
make a year that's good what does she
make a year
Alex okay what potential do you have to
increase your income it's not like it's
going to be huge choice of money like
last year decide what about a side
hustle of some kind
[Music]
what could she do while she's at home
with the kids to make some money okay
I'm going to send you a copy I'm gonna
send you a Christian copy of Christie
Wright's book business boutique
equipping one women to make money doing
what they love I don't necessarily want
to pull
out of the home but there's probably
some hours in the day she can redeem and
turn into money and you guys need it
what do you own a home well I ended up
having to combine homes with my
mother-in-law because she was not
financially prepared for retirement and
we couldn't afford our birds and her
bills and so she has her room is
mortgaged so it helped if that payment
what is her home worth I think it's
sooner in the neighborhood of 65 to 75
thousand and that's where you live yes
so you don't have a home no we are going
to chapter 13 major walk away from ours
because we couldn't afford 10 times
there's some information that's handy
okay how many years have you been in the
13 years ago yeah there you go
this is not gonna be easy you don't but
not listen you have to clean this mess
up because these student loans don't die
until you do so everything you try to
counterbalance in your brain with going
over here to do retirement and investing
as tempting as that is is going to be
offset by Sallie Mae kicking you in the
teeth every time you go take a nap and
so you're gonna have to increase income
from every possible source how much
other debt other than the three hundred
twenty-five thousand dollars in student
loan do you have that's in the thirteen
and how much do you owe on your two
vehicles fifty thousand did you say
fifty five oh okay you need to sell both
of those and close out your thirteen and
get you two hundred thousand dollar cars
you guys are freaking broke and you're
spending like you're in Congress no
wonder you ended up in a thirteen fifty
thousand dollars in vehicles with
$325,000 in student loan debt and she
stays home with the kids while you make
a hundred there's no way this math works
so you're gonna start amputating some
crap and doing some 180s all over your
life
180 into work 180 out of spending drop
the cars drop the 13 increase the income
and has tacked these student loans and
it's still gonna take you five years